hi my name is Louise and I have been a
personal trainer for five years and I
strongly believe that there is a workout
for everyone today we're gonna do a
workout whether you have five minutes 25
minutes or 15 minutes let's get started
[Music]
now we're gonna do our 5 minute workout
so if you only have five minutes focus
on your core okay that's gonna
strengthen everything else remember to
always take a 30-second break after each
exercise and go hard on those 30 seconds
of work so now we're gonna strengthen
our core by squeezing that lower back
against the floor and that's gonna
activate all the muscles in your core
and then we're gonna do that it's gonna
put your knees towards your chest and
put your hands against the knees you
know hold it for 30 seconds and the most
important thing you should focus on is
and bring your lower back against the
floor your movement is synchronized with
your breath so I want you to inhale and
exhale as you do that you'll notice your
lower back is pressing more against the
floor and you're adding an engaging more
our next exercise is called a hollow
body I'll have my arms overhead bicep
sneaks through my ears my legs are above
me this is level one you just hold this
for 30 seconds you're gonna feel your
lower back pressed against the floor and
your abs shaking level two you can go a
little bit lower and gonna hold this for
30 seconds and the more you flex your
toes the more you know feeling that
lower abdominals yes we're gonna work on
our glutes their glutes are part of your
core so we're gonna start warming up
your glutes by doing a hip bridge so we
want our feet hip width apart knees open
as well imagine you have a hundred
dollar bill between your butt cheeks and
you want to squeeze that's high you can
hold it if you notice I have a straight
line between my shoulders hips and knees
so we're gonna help you get a better
posture in everyday life so now the next
exercise we're gonna do a plank we don't
want a pyramid we want a straight
alignment between your shoulders hips
and feet and we're holding this position
for 30 seconds make sure that your
shoulders are stacked over your hands
you're breathing inhaling exhaling
squeezing a little Domino's tucking that
tailbone in hold it for anyone stronger
you want to challenge yourself you can
bring it up or down into a plank will
very slow take your time
come up and breathe but for our last
round of exercises we're gonna do our
side plank that's gonna strengthen the
sides of your core which are your
obliques shoulder stacked over your
elbow lift your hips up squeeze those
muscles here and hold it three smile
make it a habit of doing this at least
three times a week take to that habit
and once you're ready you can increase
that activity level to four times a week
if it's too much for you at home you can
start with your knees in front of you at
an angle top hand put it on the floor
and squeeze your hips forward and I
still want perfect alignment so thank
yourself we're taking these five minutes
for yourself by the end of these five
minutes you should be able to feel all
of your core muscles activated from your
tailbone all the way to your neck
all right so now we're gonna get started
with our twenty five minute workout and
it's going to be a full body workout
we're gonna start off with a yoga flow
feet facing forward at the top of our
mat we're gonna take a big inhale and
then exhale touch the toes feel it
stretching your lower back and your
hamstrings inhale feel the stretch in
your neck lengthen your spine and then
collapse touch your toes exhale inhale
into a plank hold that and then exhale
down and then inhale slide through open
up your chest open up your shoulders
tuck your toes and exhale back into a
downward dog if this is too much you can
bring your feet tall closer to your
hands didn't give you more space so you
can be more comfortable stay in this
position take three deep inhale and
exhale and then walk your feet towards
your hands big inhale take all that new
oxygen in and exhale back to standing
position
you know repeat that three times so next
up comes our organic meat and potatoes
it's gonna be a full body workout we're
gonna work on those explosive muscles so
we're gonna start off with our fast
squat for hooking linemen remember
inhale exhale the point is here I want
you go fast do this for 30 seconds if
this is too easy for you you want to get
up a notch do a jump squat whoo those
our next exercise is our push-ups I'm
gonna give you three different levels
okay level one shoulders over your hands
squeezing your butt okay we're not
perfect alignment remember always
perfect alignment I was down and
squeezing your chest really press the
floor away kind of concave your back
down and inhale exhale
you know exhale level two knees off the
floor level three time in push-up it'll
be fun
make it time in elbows back inhale
exhale inhale exhale you can't do that
too hard take a break steal a child's
pose stretch the chest your shoulders
and when you're ready get back on it
slow down but don't stop our next
exercise we're gonna do a back extension
with a hover inhale up
hover over down rest for 30 seconds do
some water now we're gonna go on our
core this is called a v-sit chest up
shoulders back lift up hold it for three
seconds hold the back of your knees
breathe and for those of you that want a
bigger challenge flip your hands up stay
here whew next up legs sit up here hands
on your hips bring the hip down squeeze
your hips and stay in alignment okay
hands behind your ears and then we're
balance twist down twist down so 30
seconds on that side then you do 30
seconds on the other side remember that
the front leg is the one that's doing
all the work the back knee is only
following the movement last one now we
can work on our hamstrings and our butt
hands on the side and exhale
by this point everything's turned on so
that was our full body workout 25
minutes all you need turn on all your
body repeat this two more times
well intense so we did a 5 minute
workout focusing on our core a 25 minute
workout focusing on full-body endurance
and now we're gonna do a 50 minute
workout focusing on a full body strength
let's do it
start by warming up our joints and when
I start off with our neck circles one
direction or a couple circles I want you
to go to the other direction I want you
to do with shoulders no roll backwards
let's do five times and then I'm gonna
go forward really releasing all the
tension from here just move your elbows
and your wrists
favorite part when you dance Amica right
now just kidding we're into our hips
forward
five times in other direction as you do
this I really want you to make big
circles I know it's gonna feel a little
weird but don't worry you're at home no
one's watching next time put your hands
on your knees five circles one direction
and other direction five times row to
the ankles one direction in the other
direction and that's it
so we're done with our warmup and now
we're gonna get strong and we're gonna
do that by doing five sets of exercises
each set it's gonna have two exercises
and you know repeat each set three times
after each set you're gonna rest for 45
seconds you're gonna need a mat and one
set of dumbbells it could be ten pounds
or 15 pound dumbbells and that's it for
exercise we're gonna do it sumo squat
it's too much squats gonna work on your
inner thighs and it's an exercise and
now I'm gonna be putting know about one
dumbbell open your feet wide both toes
in one direction it was like a tuck you
know walk down bending through your
knees and then engaging through inner
thighs and your butt tuck your tailbone
in and that's one rep this is super
important especially if you're working
on a desk because you're always sitting
down and he's inner thighs stay weak but
if you want a bigger challenge can grab
this other dumbbell curved foot ends
come together and squeeze you do 15 of
these
now we're gonna super set this with ABS
this next exercise is called a
windshield wiper and out to the side
like tea nice the side and squeeze your
abdominals back to Center you're gonna
do this for 30 seconds make sure you're
lifting from your obliques once you're
done with that you're gonna rest for 45
seconds and then you do it all over
again two more times
you're really gonna put your inner
thighs and your core we're gonna do our
lunges 90 degrees and then degrees
pressing from this heel and you give me
15 up and then down and then up
in doubt yes okay so now after we do
their legs we're gonna work on your core
bring your shoulders back
put your hands below your lower back
clasp um come down here and you know
flutter kick for 30 seconds stay strong
breathe focus if you want a challenge
lift your head up look at your toes all
right so we just finished set number two
rest for 45 seconds get some water
you're doing amazing you do this two
more times for a total of three now
we're gonna go to set number three
shifting gears to upper body and
shoulders so we're gonna start off on
our hand there knees we're gonna do a
downward dog and a Pike pushup okay for
level one I want to start with a
downward dog and shift into a plank easy
you're gonna do 15 of these and remember
this is all of your body weight you want
to be strong and being able to hold our
own body weight before we pick up any
weights so mass for this first and it's
okay if you're here it's totally okay
remember don't compare yourself to
anyone and only compare yourself to you
how strong you were yesterday and want
to be stronger tomorrow all of this is
more mental than physical and if this is
too hard it's totally fine
take a break here Simpson down one dog
come back here plank if you want more of
a challenge put your feet flat on the
floor and we're gonna do a Pike pushup
from this position it's the bend your
elbows and press shoulder workout now
we're gonna do 30 seconds of traveling
mountain climbers and I'm pretty sure
you haven't seen you before
leg straight you know put your knees
towards your elbow level one stay here
for 30 seconds breathe straight line
don't do this then don't do this stay
close
breathe just for 30 seconds you must
spice it up you travel
breathe don't forget to breathe
especially in this position so there's
gonna be on fire place how you get
strong almost there
whoa so rest for 45 seconds repeat this
two more times for next set we're gonna
do tricep kickbacks I'm gonna use ten
pound dumbbells if you don't have that
repaired um bills it's totally fine you
can use use your arm bodyweight okay I
want you to roll your shoulders back do
10 you have a pencil behind your
shoulder blades squeeze hard hinge from
your hips slightly slight bend in your
knees not too much pour your elbows for
the ceiling this is the fun part you're
gonna snap back your wrists to really
squeeze back 315 hold and release good
now we're working our core I'm gonna go
in our plank holding here we're going to
go into a plank and then we're gonna tap
each shoulder take your time with this
one the most important thing is for your
hips to not move you want a bigger
challenge come down hold and come back
up stay there
hold down alternating for 30 seconds
shimmy the shoulders back take a rest
and we're gonna do it again two more
times I'm gonna feel beat remember this
is not easy but you just need to like
just create that momentum just do this
for 15 minutes maybe three times a week
twice a week get that ball rolling once
you get that ball rolling you start
getting momentum feeling better stay
true stay committed and you're gonna see
you changes in three weeks I promise
last set you guys been waiting for it's
gonna do biceps and we're gonna do back
so we hit all parts of our body you're
gonna get your light dumbbells either
College twenty-one so we're gonna do
seven reps on the lower portion
of the bicep curl then we do seven on
the top portion after that we're gonna
do seven full bicep curls whoo that's
arms just know that this is not gonna
get you bulky use the lighter weight and
is gonna give you nice toned arms now
we're do back extensions
we're always standing like this on our
desk crunched forward but we're never
going the opposite direction so this is
what we're gonna work on so you lay down
arms extended and you lift up your legs
and your arms I'm gonna do this for 30
seconds whew that's it you did it
it's arrest for 45 seconds repeat this
two more times and there you have it
that was our five minute our 25 minute
and our 50 minute workout I hope you
give one of these a try and always
remember that there is always time to
take care of your body and to be
healthier
[Music]
you
[Music]